Less than four months after blastoff from Earth,...
...the Centaur rocket in LCROSS spacecraft slammed into the moon,...
...just as Project Manager Dan Andrews hoped they would.
I'm happy to report that the spacecraft performed beautifully throughout the mission.
The operations team drove it well.
The mission aimed to confirm the presence of water on the moon.
As shown in this animation, scientists expected a giant plume of dirt and dust,...
...possibly with evidence of water produced by the crashes.
But it was difficult to see any debris in pictures beamed back to Earth by the satellite before impact.
The principal investigator in the mission, Anthony Colaprete, said...
...it is too early to draw conclusions about whether a dust cloud existed.
But if there was no plume...
We lose some.
We lose, you know, what we hope to get out of the ejected cloud was...
...an ability to say "Aha! we see this much stuff, this much dirt",...
...and we could somehow relate that to how much actually came out of the crater.
Colaprete says his team focused on the Cabeus crater,...
...an area near the moon's south pole that is permanently in the dark.
If there is water on the moon, it could be frozen in that crater indefinitely.
Even if the pictures are not definitive, instruments on the spacecraft,...
...combined with observers on Earth...
...and the Hubble Telescope collected data from the mission.
It could take up to 2 months before scientists can conclude if water exists here.